-We got more
bombshell revelations
from the committee investigating
Donald Trump's attempted coup
on January 6th.
Today, the committee released
new evidence
that Trump and one of the key
plotters in the coup,
a lawyer named John Eastman,
knew their plan
would violate the law
and that same lawyer also
had direct contact
with Ginni Thomas,
the wife of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas,
in the lead-up to January 6th.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
These hearings keep providing us
with more damning evidence
that Trump's attempted coup
wasn't just some spontaneous
outbreak of mob violence.
It was a detailed plan
orchestrated by figures,
including Trump himself,
who had criminal intent
and who almost certainly
knew what they were doing
was illegal.
I know, on one level,
that's obvious,
but it's still important
to establish.
It's kind of like how you know
the mysterious British husband
in an HBO miniseries
is the bad guy,
just from looking at him.
[ Laughter ]
But you still need to like
watch Hugh Grant
push a dude out a window,
just to be sure.
[ Laughter ]
And, even then,
Nicole Kidman's character
will probably still be like,
"I just don't know what
to think.
Fetch me my giant shawl.
I need to go
for a midnight walk."
[ Laughter ]
For example, the committee
played new video
from a deposition with Pence's
former chief of staff
Marc Short,
where Short said Pence has made
clear many times to Trump
that he had no authority
to unilaterally overturn
the election.
-Was it your impression
that the vice president
had directly conveyed
his position
on these issues
to the president?
Not just to the world,
through a Dear Colleague letter,
but directly to President Trump?
-Many times.
-And had been consistent
in conveying his position
to the president?
-Very consistent.
-Although, no matter how
consistent you are with Trump,
you know he's going
to keep pushing.
The dude probably can't buy
a toothbrush at CVS
without haggling.
"That'll be $2.99."
[ As Trump ]
Alright, how about you
throw in five bucks
and a lifetime supply
of toilet paper?
[ Laughter ]
"No."
[ As Trump ]
Alright, what if you just
give me the toothbrush for free?
"No."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Alright.
How about this?
I'll give you $2.99,
you give me the toothbrush,
and we'll call it even.
[ Laughter ]
"Alright, yeah, fine."
[ As Trump ]
Another successful deal
by The Donald.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm going to turn this around
and sell it for $2.49,
and then who's laughing?
[ Laughter ]
In fact, in a meeting in the
Oval Office on January 4th,
the lawyer pushing the plan
to have Pence
overturn the election,
a guy named John Eastman,
admitted that his plan
would violate the law,
according to a deposition
from a Pence lawyer named
Greg Jacob.
We'll have more to say
on this meeting later,
but here's what Jacob had
to say in that deposition
about Eastman admitting,
in front of Trump,
that his plan
would break the law.
-When, exactly,
did President Trump know
that it would be illegal
for Mike Pence
to refuse to count
electoral votes?
Here is one sample of testimony,
given by one of the witnesses
before us today,
the vice president's
general counsel.
-Did John Eastman ever admit,
as far as you know,
in front of the president,
that his proposal would violate
the Electoral Count Act?
-I believe he did on the 4th.
-So, that means Trump knew
it was illegal.
Even his own pro-coup lawyer
admitted it was illegal,
and yet, he still tried
to threaten and coerce Pence
into doing it, to the point
where he basically sicced
the violent mob on Pence
to get him to do it.
I'm no lawyer, but how is
that not an indictable offense?
I feel like even Nicole Kidman
would say,
"Oh, yeah,
he's definitely guilty.
[ Laughter ]
I don't need the shawl
for this one."
[ Laughter ]
By the way, this comes on top
of all the evidence
already provided
by the first two hearings,
that Trump
and everyone around him
knew his stolen election claims
were false
and that they were
just fabricated pretext
for a premeditated plan
to overturn the election.
In fact, there was actually
supposed to be
another hearing before today,
but that hearing, originally
scheduled for Wednesday,
was postponed
for mysterious reasons.
So far, members of the committee
have said the reasons
for that postponement
have been technical --
they need to give
their team more time
to produce the materials,
specifically, the video clips
needed for each hearing.
-I understand there is a bit
of a change in the schedule,
pertaining
to tomorrow's hearing.
Do you know anything
about when it will be?
What's going on?
-I think we're just firming up.
There's no big deal,
but I'll tell you.
Putting together the video
and exhibits
is an exhausting exercise
-Yeah.
-for our very small,
you know, video staff,
so, we're trying to --
You know,
we were going to have one,
two, three in one week
and it's just it's too much
to put it all together.
-I get it. We also have
a small staff pulling
and cutting together video clips
three days a week
for our "Closer Looks."
True story.
Here's a real picture
of our "Closer Look"
video researcher Emily
from when she started
on this show.
And here she is
after eight years
of watching Fox News clips.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, damn it!
Guys, we got to deprogram
Emily again.
[ Laughter ]
You know, if producing
these hearings
is getting too hard
for you guys,
you know what you should do?
You should just do them
from your attic at home.
[ Laughter ]
No audience, no crew,
just Liz Cheney, an iPad camera,
and an annoying painting
of a Sea Captain
in the background.
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
People don't know this
about Liz Cheney --
she's actually a huge
Sea Captain fan.
[ Laughter ]
This is true --
after we came back to the studio
and stopped featuring him
on the show,
I called her up and asked her
what she thought
of the Sea Captain
and she told me --
-"Please get him on tv."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Anyway, the reason they gave
for postponing Wednesday's
hearing was logistical,
though Congresswoman Zoe Lofgren
did provide this tantalizing
hint that, perhaps,
they had also learned
some new information
that made them delay
that hearing until next week.
-Explain to us why
tomorrow is postponed
and how we should understand
that affecting the rest
of the hearings.
-Well, I don't think it's going
to have much of any impact.
We had a lot of hearings
compressed together
and there were
logistical problems
that are going to be avoided
by kicking one of the hearings
over to next week.
-There's no reason
that I should think like,
"Oh, there's something going on.
They learned a new thing,
a witness backed out,"
et cetera?
-Well, you know, we're
constantly learning new things,
but this is
primarily logistical.
-"Primarily."
[ Laughter ]
-I'll just leave it at that.
-Ooh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is quite the tease.
I do like that members
of Congress
who've spent their whole lives
learning when to talk and when
to keep something secret
are suddenly turning
into high school gossips,
[ Laughter ]
now that they've got secret dirt
the rest of us want to know.
[ Changes accent ]
Did you hear about Rudy?
He was wasted
at the party last night.
[ Campy voice ]
"Is that why he's not
in school today?"
Mostly.
"Mostly"?!
He also hooked up
with his cousin.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Second, I hope."
Yeah, second.
He got wasted, first,
and hooked up
with his cousin second.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was definitely the order.
Say what you will
about this committee,
but they do know how
to build suspense.
At the end of Monday's hearing,
for example,
they played a preview clip
teasing what was to come.
It was a clip from a deposition
with former White House lawyer
Eric Herschmann,
describing a conversation
he had with Eastman.
Here's a fuller clip that was
released later,
of Herschmann describing
that conversation with Eastman
after the attack on January 6th.
I screamed...
-[ Laughs ]
-And I screamed --
[ Laughter ]
Damn, that guy should
definitely audition
for the next season
of "Billions."
[ Laughter ]
The guy you'd be playing
is a hardass lawyer
who has a baseball bat
with "Justice" written on it.
[ As Herschmann ]
Hey!
I [bleep] already got one
of those!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Excuse me.
Effing got one of those.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, as we've explained,
Eastman is obviously a key
figure in the coup attempt.
For example, even though
Eastman apparently admitted
that his plan
would break the law,
Trump still tried to get Pence
to go through
with Eastman's plan,
in a heated Oval Office meeting
where Trump kept telling Pence
to listen to Eastman.
-Stunning new details
on Donald Trump's efforts
to overturn the 2020 election,
from the new book "Peril,"
by Bob Woodward
and Robert Costa.
The authors report on a two-page
memo drafted by John Eastman.
John Eastman is
a conservative lawyer
who was working
for Trump's legal team.
It amounts to a blueprint
for a coup.
NBC News has later
obtained the memo.
It outlines how Pence was
to have disrupted
the certification of the
Electoral College results
and handed the election
to Trump.
Trump tells Pence this
about Eastman...
-He is not a respected
constitutional scholar.
No respected
constitutional scholar
would ever be
caught dead working
for a famously corrupt idiot
like Donald Trump.
Trump gets all his lawyers
from bus stop ads
and TV commercials.
[ As Giuliani ]
Hey, you want to do a coup?
Call Eastman & Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
We don't have a phone number,
but you can find us
at our office
in the woods at Central Park.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Even though the cops
are always hassling us.
[ Laughter ]
We need a permit for a desk
in the park now? Alright.
[ Laughter ]
And, even in advance
of today's hearing,
we kept getting more
and more details
about the scope of this coup
attempt and who was involved.
For example, we found out
yesterday that Ginni Thomas,
the wife of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas,
had a direct contact
with Eastman
and that the
January 6th Committee
has obtained those emails.
-The Washington Post
is reporting tonight
the January 6th Committee
"has obtained..."
...who played a key role
in efforts to pressure
Vice President Mike Pence
to block the certification
of Joe Biden's victory.
-The spouse of a sitting
Supreme Court justice
was apparently
in direct communication
with the key figure
in the planning of a coup.
That seems like a pretty clear
conflict of interest.
It's like if I found out
my parents were doing
this year's Thanksgiving show
with James Corden.
[ Laughter ]
Good luck, James!
Good luck, buddy.
Hope you're fully stocked
on Grey Goose.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not saying justices' spouses
should always come into play
or be scrutinized,
but in this case,
it seems pretty clear.
I mean, Ginni Thomas
also reportedly pressured
Arizona lawmakers to overturn
their state's results
and texted Trump's
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
about a bunch of truly insane
election fraud
conspiracy theories.
How can the Supreme Court
just ignore that?
In fact, the texts to Meadows,
in particular,
are truly shocking.
At one point, Thomas wrote
to Meadows...
And in another,
she quoted a passage
that had circulated
on right-wing websites...
And then again,
she texted Meadows,
"Do not concede..."
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
Those texts make Mike Lindell
sound like
a levelheaded businessman.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Lindell ]
That lady is crazier
than a [bleep]house rat,
and I should know,
because you should hear
the things the rats whisper
to me
when I'm sleeping under
da stairs!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, here's the thing.
Here's the thing.
You rats want jobs
inside a pillowcase?
[ Laughter ]
Don't think of it
as being stuffing!
[ Laughter ]
Now, here's the thing.
I know those texts
all sound insane to you,
but it's important to remember
they really are
[bleep] insane. I think
[ Laughter and applause ]
my favorite part is
when she says
the "Biden crime family & ballot
fraud co-conspirators...
will be living
in barges off GITMO."
[ Laughter ]
Obviously,
all this stuff is bonkers,
but I am curious
about one thing --
why would they live
in a barge off GITMO?
[ Laughter ]
Like, why wouldn't they just be
sent to GITMO?
Why would Trump, who, I guess,
I don't know,
would be the supreme leader
in this scenario,
incur the extra cost
[ Laughter ]
of running a barge offshore?
I mean, you got staff,
maintenance, you got weather.
Why wouldn't he just put them
in a cell inside GITMO
and save himself all that?
And why am I
pitching ideas on this?
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is how they get you,
isn't it?
This is how they got Emily.
[ Laughter ]
That's how they got Emily.
By the way, just last month,
Clarence Thomas gave a speech
where he said that the judiciary
is threatened,
if people are unwilling to...
As well as saying...
And that was him bitching
that someone leaked
a draft opinion
that would overturn Roe v Wade.
Meanwhile, his wife is burning
through her cellphone data plan,
texting everyone
in their contacts list
that it's time for an army
to gather
because an election
didn't break her way.
"We need to live with outcomes
we don't agree with.
Now, let's get those barges
ready for the Bidens!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Lindell ] Whoa!
Cool down, Ginni.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Once again, these hearings
have provided
more damning evidence
that Trump and his cronies
knew what they were doing
would violate the law,
and tried to do it anyway.
It was a detailed,
orchestrated plan for a coup
and they almost got
away with it.
Again, I'm not a lawyer,
but if you genuinely think
Trump didn't commit a crime,
all I can say is...
-"Are you
out of your effing mind?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.